so I pull up to my house and this is
[ __ ] whatever state truck there but
these [ __ ] guys are in my yard the
gates open and one of the guys got a
ladder up to the side of my house so I
just walk in I'm like yeah hey what are
you guys doing then he goes up god
summer finally somebody's home I'm like
what do you mean my wife didn't let you
in he was like no there was no answer
and I'm like then what are you doing
here
he goes well you know I keep coming by
there's nobody here I got to check the
meter you know they said you put a new
electrical box you know you guys are
never home and what was I supposed to do
I was like I don't know not coming to my
[ __ ] yard what was I supposed to do
every time I go to the bank the bags
closed I mean what was I supposed to do
come back when they're [ __ ] there yet
[ __ ] he just kept saying what was I
supposed to do you're trespassing you
[ __ ] the [ __ ] he just kept saying
what I'm you know something I actually
kept my cool though I just calmly said I
don't know not coming in my yard I go
off my if I keep going over my
neighbor's house and he's not there that
doesn't mean give me a right to go in
there he goes well I got to go over I
got to get to the pole I mean you know
when they changed the box they only put
temporary whatever [ __ ] things on
there I got to put the right things on
there I don't have your phone number I'm
like well whose fault is that semi fault
nobody asked me you guys never called me
oh I guess you couldn't call me but you
should have got from the from the
electrician he goes yeah the electrician
didn't give it to me why go there you go
so the other guy is grabbing the ladder
he takes it down he's [ __ ] walking
out I go you know what do you want you
need to do here he goes no no you know
go get out of here it's a sec dudes you
don't got a [ __ ] pot now you know
what I'm saying is right you just opened
the gate you just [ __ ] walk in
unbelievable
I mean what was I supposed to do I [ __ ]
you melius what were you supposed to do